he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
ventures endgame gets its first trailer
and title yes we've been speculating
since the Russo brothers dropped that
photo in September with the caption look
hard and now we know it spells out and
game very cryptic I'm ash cross and
joined by GameSpot's micro Joe and we're
gonna talk about our feelings about the
title and the trailer first of all how
do you feel about the title end game I
love the title I think it's a great
title I think it spells out everything
we need to know the thing that I'm less
okay with this how they rolled it out
like it was gonna be this huge
mind-blowing reveal what is the title of
this movie you'll never guess and we
kind of did guess everybody kind of saw
this coming that's the thing a lot of
people guessed it and then to the point
where the Russo brothers are like no
that's not it
right and then it was yeah but I was
having fun with like a cryptic part of
the photo I was trying to figure it out
but oh yeah the photo that they released
yeah I loved playing I spied I thought
that was really fun but just tell us
already yeah how'd you feel about the
trailer was there anybody who wanted to
see that wasn't in it or vice versa
I love the trailer look how sad it was
because like I saw infinity war so I am
sad and you are probably sad and we're
all sad were sad I'm so that was great I
really wanted to see Hawkeye in it
because he wasn't in infinity war and we
did he's got a new look yeah Hawkeye is
Ronin I think is really cool from the
comics I wanted to see ant-man because
of how that movie ended with him stuck
in the quantum realm like is he gonna be
in this movie how does he get out we
don't know the answer yet but we saw him
in it and I thought it was a cool
trailer I wanted to see Captain Marvel
in that trailer I know it I know I get
it like it would have been a little bit
of a real but we just got the Captain
Marvel trailer days prior so it made me
feel like they were teeing it up for
maybe giving some kind of reveal her on
the other end of that beeper something
like that yeah that would have been cool
out I mean I agree but what I really
wasn't okay with in that trailer
Captain America not having a beard yeah
where's his beard it has been many since
snowpiercer he has had a beard had a
beard and he doesn't have the beard
anymore and I hate it and also hit like
the single tear sliding down his face
just made him seem like a baby like a
barefaced
crying baby and I'd know when he was
introducing that infinity war trailer
and he steps out with the beard I was
like okay that's a daddy and now No
longer Dada daddy at all not a daddy I'm
not okay with Sheree
apparently being dead which is something
that we saw in this trailer at first I'm
glad you brought this up because I
didn't notice the suppers yes so when
Mark Ruffalo is looking at the screen
that has Scott Lang's face on it over to
the left is latisha right Sheree and
then it quickly changes to Tom Holland
so people some people didn't notice it
but yeah it does that mean that she's
you don't got I assume so I'm not okay
with that at all no that's terrible not
okay with Cherie who would you be okay
with saying goodbye to because it seems
like we're gonna lose somebody yeah I'm
not multiple I would be okay saying
goodbye to most of the original crew
because it's been a decade and they're
probably tired and I'm ready for a new
generation of Avengers and to do that we
need to say goodbye to the Oklahomans
I'm okay with that yeah I'm ready for
the the new generation I I wouldn't be
okay with Thor because I feel like he's
just gotten his like revival of a new
kind of era of Thor and I loved Ragnarok
and I want more Thor's but I'd be okay
with Captain America and Tony for sure
well what if we get more Thor but it's
just about gurney finished by I'm okay
with that I'm definitely okay with that
okay so we passed it all out definitive
answer title and trailer are you okay
with it I am okay with it
I'm okay with it I'm very okay with it
and we want to hear from you guys let us
know if you're okay with the title of
Enders endgame would your prediction
who's gonna make it out alive let us
know I'm a - Carlson and I'm at rogue
cheddar thank you guys so much and we're
okay with it